sciences bonjour et bienvenue pour cette
option se consacrer aujourd'hui annie
sis plus connu sous le nom de monstre du
loch ness des monstres tout le monde
quoi en voir partout tout le temps et
internet n'a pas arrangé les choses
une photo mal cadré une impression
vagues dans le regard un flou plus
artistique que d'habitude
et paf la rumeur est lancée et c'est le
buzz mais bon tous ces trucs avant
d'être des monstres ce sont surtout et
avant tout des corps mutilés par la
décomposition et l'eau de mer d'animaux
qui eux sont bien réels ça ce sont les
faits mais ceux qui disent voir des
monstres saute l'étape de la
constatation des faits pour passer
directement à l'interprétation dire j'ai
vu un monstre n'est pas un fait c'est
votre interprétation du fait j'ai vu
quelque chose de moche
donc ça c'est un truc moche qui
ressemble à un monstre mais sa dentition
est aussi typiquement celle d'un [ __ ]
laveur ou de quelque chose qui s'en
rapproche
ça c'est un truc moche aussi qui
ressemble à un monstre mais aussi un peu
un lama serge pas toi non mais les
taupes ci a finalement montré qu'il
s'agissait d'un banal paresseux dont la
décomposition avait fait tomber le
pelage on continue d'en regarder le truc
au bout de cette perche blanche là ça
ressemble à un ver géant façon d'une et
avec ce cadrage là bas ça ressemble
plutôt à un bête poisson qu'on appelle
une lamproie un serpent de mer avec des
cheveux à moins que ça soit une orque
échoué donc nous disions les monstres
tout le monde croit au revoir tout le
temps et c'est pas nouveau
voici l'un des monstres et les plus
vieux qui soit ni si parfois appelé le
loch ness du nom du lac écossais qu il
abriterait voici le cliché le plus connu
de nessie c'est la photo dit du
chirurgien car elle a été faite par un
gynécologue
les spéculations quant à cette photo
vont bon train et même ceux qui ne
veulent pas croire en l'existence de
nessie ne manquent pas d'imagination
mais il y en a une qui remporte
l'approbation la plus large du grand
public
messi serait un plésiosaure mais non pas
un dinosaure un plésiosaure un reptile
marin ayant vécu durant l'ère mésozoïque
il ya entre 240 et 65 millions d'années
mais qui n'a rien à voir avec un
dinosaure
ce serait super sexy avant centre marin
préhistorique vivant dans le loch ness
oui mais voilà la liste des faits bien
réels eux qu'il vous faudrait n'y es
pour qu'un monstre ou un plésiosaure
vivant existe dans le loch ness est très
longue
et voici les plus importants
premièrement les plésiosaures sont des
descendants de reptiles terrestres ce ne
sont pas des poissons donc signer ci est
un plésiosaure il doit avoir des poumons
et doivent remonter régulièrement à la
surface pour respirer endroits où nous
devrions pouvoir l'observer sans trop de
problème comme on le fait pour les
baleines par exemple et là je sais ce
que vous allez me dire oui mais le
coelacanthe et des câlins géant eux
aussi on croyait qu'il n'existait pas on
les a découvert quand même
et en fait ils étaient cachés oui mais
voilà le coelacanthe et le calmar géant
eux peuvent s'oxygéner sous l'eau et
donc ils vivre sans jamais remonté à la
surface
d'ailleurs l'un comme l'autre vivent ta
grande profondeur dont il ne remonte
presque pas le monstre du loch ness si
tenté qu'il s'agisse d'un plésiosaures
ne pourrait pas se cacher indéfiniment
dans les profondeurs du loch profondeur
qui ne sont d'ailleurs pas si grande
puisque le loch ness n'est qu'un lac du
scion nous le rappeler
les baleines qui ont la planète entière
pour se planquer ne nous ont pas échappé
et n'ont surtout pas échappé aux
japonais alors comment necid dans son
tout petit lac
il serait il parvenu le brouillard
il ya souvent du brouillard comme ca en
brut 1
non seulement on continue nos pneus et
ses incursions sur le milieu terrestre
serait d'autant plus visible que
peut-être il devrait y pondre des oeufs
ou peut-être pas comme le suggère le
fossile de plésiosaure retrouvait avec
un petit en gestation dans son ventre et
sans aucune trace de 9 au tour ce qui
suggère qu'il devait accoucher comme des
cétacés
deuxièmement le loch ness croule est
encore sous un immense glacier il ya
encore dix mille ans de cela durant la
dernière ère glaciaire et même si un peu
d'eau aurait pu rester liquide sous ce
tag glace comme au lac vostok en
antarctique par exemple ce qui est très
improbable alors l'immense pression que
cette épaisseur de glace aurait exercées
sur le monstre 360 fois la pression
atmosphérique au lac vostok
merci cette pression donc l'eau réduit
en dés à coudre et commencer poids avec
les scénarios de science fiction du
genre il aurait survécu congelés c'est
n'importe quoi
troisièmement les plésiosaures son marin
alors que le loch ness et un lac d'eau
douce située à 16 mètres d'altitude
messi aurait certes pu s'adapter mais en
à peine dix mille ans ça fait quand même
un peu court
enfin dernièrement on parle souvent du
loch ness ou de necid pour désigner le
monstre mais il est bien évident que
s'il existe n'est ci n'est pas tout seul
haas a certainement pas seule une
population entière de plésiosaure
auraient pu survivre et ceux perpétrés
pendant 65 millions d'années voire plus
à moins que ce ne soit un mathusalem aux
à tout le problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas
assez de ressources dans le loch ness
pour supporter une population de grands
reptiles piscivores comme des
plésiosaures les autres turbines et
sombre du loch ness ne laisse pas
filtrer beaucoup de lumière donc le
plancton végétal ne peut pas s'y
développer et cette absence de végétaux
course cuite toute la chaîne alimentaire
dé sa base les plésiosaures est-il
reptiles piscivores comme en témoignent
leurs dents qui sont parfaites pour
harponner le poisson donc signer ci est
un plésiosaure alors il devrait être
situé au sommet de cette chaîne
alimentaire aux pieds d'argile
rendez vous compte le loch ness compte à
peine 22 tonnes de poissons sachant que
dans la nature la biomasse de grands
carnivores est à peu près de 10% de
celles de ses proies
cela veut dire qu'en théorie le loch
ness ne peut accueillir que deux 2
deux monstres ça vous fait un seul et
unique monstre de taille correcte mais
qui aurait vécu seul dans le lac pendant
à peu près 65 millions d'années
ça fait un peu vieux quand même ou bien
dit monstres de la taille d'un cochon et
qui aurait été fortement consanguins ou
bien encore une centaine de monstres de
2 kg la plus de problèmes de
consanguinité simplement un problème de
monstruosité ben oui comment avoir l'air
monstrueux quand on est moins gros qu'un
chat
alors laquelle de ces hypothèses vous
semble la moins d' inacceptable tapez 1
pour le mathusalem aux ordres pdf pour
les lattes cochon et tapez 3 pour
leucate naissent en conclusion quelle
que soit l'interprétation que vous
choisissez parmi ces deux là elles ont
en commun qu'elles partent du principe
que l'animal représenté sur la
photographie est bien réelle mais comme
vous l'aurez compris aucune des deux n'a
paraît sérieusement soutenu par les
faits or les faits les voici la photo
originale révèle la taille tout à fait
ridicule du soi-disant monstre mais en
vérité le fait que cette photo est été
une supercherie n'est plus un secret
depuis 1975
alors pourquoi cet engouement pour un
monstre fantoches déjà il ya le contexte
historique
imaginez si on est britannique
concernant les monstres préhistoriques
et au début du siècle dernier enflammé
par les spectaculaires découverte de
mary anning fait cinquante ans plus tôt
ces découvertes avait d'ailleurs donné
naissance à l'exposition du crystal
palace
la première montrant des animaux
préhistoriques reconstitué grandeur
nature et mise en scène par le
terrifiant ce richard howe
l'engouement pour les monstres
préhistoriques en ce début de xxème
siècle atteint son comble avec la
publication puis l'adaptation au cinéma
du monde perdu deux soeurs arthur conan
doyle
puis la sortie au cinéma du tout premier
king kong en 1933
et curieusement c'est à peu près à cette
même époque compte était pour la
première fois observé big foot et le
monstre du loch ness coïncident j'en
doute fort
moralité il ne faut pas se précipiter
sur l'interprétation aussi attirante
soit elle à la vue de cette photo
immédiatement notre cerveau nous crie
j'ai vu un plésiosaure mais ce que vous
voyez en fait c'est une image fortement
agrandie du nombre ayant une allure de
plésiosaure mais ce pourrait tout aussi
bien être une souche mutante ou un
cormoran ou bien simplement un port
attention n'allez pas croire que nous
faisons ici les scepticismes à outrance
et que les scientifiques de manière
générale sont complètement hermétique et
tous les témoignages en faveur du
monstre du loch ness
en vérité s'il y avait de bonnes raisons
de croire qu'il existe encore un
plésiosaure vivant en écosse alors tous
les paléontologues du monde y accourent
est évident ray le lac à la paille s'il
le faut pour le découvrir
les scientifiques sont sceptiques oui
mais pas fou il ne voudrait surtout pas
passer à côté de la découverte la plus
sexy du siècle mais voilà le loch ness
comme tout le reste de l'europe est loin
d'être l'endroit le moins fréquenté du
monde et plus aucune espèce nouvelle
d'une taille supérieure à 2 g ni a été
découverte depuis une centaine d'années
en france par exemple la dernière espèce
de mammifère de taille correcte qui a
été découvert est une toute petite taupe
subaquatique le desman des pyrénées et
c'était en 1811
les faits sont aussi qu' après 100 ans
d'investigations d'observation en
surface à l'oeil nu ou avec des caméras
ou en sous main bien encore avec des
bateaux armés de sauna et un parcouru le
loch ness de part en part et ce
plusieurs fois et le tout sachant que la
région du loch ness est tout sauf un
désert humain rien de concluant n'a été
trouvé donc si vous tenez toujours à
croire que le monstre du loch ness
existe autant vous dire qu'à part des
photos floues et quelques rumeurs et
témoignages contradictoires
il n'existe rien de tangible pour aller
dans ce sens car il faudrait beaucoup
mieux que quelques indices médiocre pour
attester de la présence d'une créature à
un endroit où son existence même
transgresserait toutes les lois de la
biologie et de la logique la plus
élémentaire
par contre les dégâts écologiques de
cette chasse aux courants d'air comme
l'introduction d'espèces invasives
accrochés aux bateaux venus de
l'étranger eux sont palpables et les
retombées financières qui vont avec
aussi d'ailleurs
pour en savoir plus nous vous
recommandons de ne pas croire tout ce
qui traîne sur le net ainsi que la
lecture du livre pour l'instant en
anglais et dominer ibos heinz et surtout
n'oubliez pas que de la même façon qu'un
grand pouvoir implique de lourdes
responsabilités formulé deux grandes
hypothèses demande de fournir des
preuves qui envoie du lourd pour les
étayer
merci à tous